joining us here on the rich eisen show
from the worldwide leader in sports is
diane russini how are you diana
hi rich i'm wonderful how are you doing
in beautiful los angeles your tweet your
tweet caught my eye today i'm not gonna
lie
it definitely caught my eye about aaron
rodgers making his decision so what can
you tell me what do you got for me on
this front
so i was told that the decision is going
to be coming soon within the next week
or so okay that he's going to inform the
green bay packers that he's either
staying in wisconsin or he's going to
ask for a trade or he's going to retire
as the three options that we are all
very aware of retire
that's still an option here retire that
would be surprising to me
though so
i'm not betting anything on that one but
right so the way i'm i'm i i'm reading
in between the lines of your tweet and
you tell me if i might be onto something
here is part of his decision is whatever
contract might be on the table and
whatever negotiations might be on the
table between
he and the packers like he can't really
inform his decision whether he wants to
go
um until he sees
uh what the packers are putting on the
table money funny money how
just look looking at a contract you'll
you'll see the expiration date that the
packers are willing to extend this to
what do you think about that
yeah it would it would make a lot of
sense for him to protect himself to see
what the green bay packers are going to
be
willing to pay him because
from the conversations i've had with a
lot of people in the league he wants to
be the highest paid player in the nfl
by a wide margin
so we're talking about
50 million a year
and
we know the
cap situation the green bay packers are
in we know davonte adams right needs to
get paid so there's a there's a lot on
the table um and speaking of tables
there's also multiple teams that
are waiting to see what happens here
because
they are hoping and willing to make a
trade for him
that's a large chunk of the pie right
there 50 50 mil a year that's what he's
looking for
right now
that's what i was told so that's around
the number he's looking for per year you
know and when you when you match that up
with the other quarterbacks
around the league right now in terms of
that that annual
uh you know that annual chunk of change
i guess um right so we have
patrick mahomes josh allen you know
patrick's about 46 million a year should
be about
you know what's the math there four
million more
yeah uh
you know and
at 38 years old that's that's a high
price yeah
wow um how much calf space does the
broncos have i mean like who has the cap
space to to
if rogers does
get a contract offer back from green bay
that is not that much and say hey you
have to give a hometown discount for
devonte you want devonte right i mean
you got to have him um let's just say
that the numbers come back and he
says i want out who's got the ability to
pay him that
do you know i'm so i'm so glad you asked
that because even speaking to teams that
are not in the hunt that are not in this
trade race right let's say um trying to
understand all right if you had to make
it work how would you do it
um
rich you've been covering this league
long enough it
it's figured out it's it they can make
it work and
one team i spoke with that is in the
hunt
when i looked at their numbers it didn't
completely make sense to me
but i was told it would work out we will
find a way it will work out
so sometimes that means that the
detriment of other players money
obviously
uh
perhaps maybe even cutting some players
to make more room
um
but i know the teams that are interested
in him are
getting creative
and and are getting a little impatient
here as they're waiting because they
have to make moves themselves so while
the green bay packers are waiting for
this answer some of the other teams
because we all know three agencies right
around the corner yeah
oh man so um
so those people have placed uh on the
table those are the ones who have uh
fully baked like here's what we're
willing to give um draft choices like
those have been
forwarded to brian guterkoons he has
them all on his desk if he so chooses to
lay them out there paperwork style i was
told
the green bay packers
for for what it's worth we're not told
from those teams
um what what the compensation would be
you know what the package would look
like because that's tampering um they
can't call over to green bay yet
um apparently because they need to have
this conversation with aaron so i'm not
sure how the working or how the dealings
have been going in terms of
the context and the true communication
because you gotta figure there's
something there
um
but the teams that i've spoken to that
that want him
have been working towards putting this
together to make it work for green bay
happy combine week huh like this is
literally hanging over the combine
because everything because
the talk next week is going to be
even louder about how there are no
surefire uh franchise quarterbacks in
this draft
and uh who wants to take a big swing at
aaron rodgers right
if
it's available like this is literally
the conversation next week when you
agree it will it will be a miserable
week rich if when i see you there
hopefully aaron rodgers decision has not
been made by them now i do think it
would be interesting to see what would
happen after his decisions made and if
his decision is to leave
what would happen because there's a lot
of tentacles to this of how this would
go down
would green bay agree
for the for the trade package would they
be okay with that is would that team be
okay for airing would you want to go to
that team
um
you know you kind of have and then
perhaps what if a team that has a
current quarterback has to
figure out a way to trade their
quarterback to a different team if green
bay doesn't want them you know what i
mean there's so many layers to this
uh depending on
organization game for aaron rodner's
that's in that's which
right now so i think the easy part here
believe it or not after months and
months a month the easy part in all this
is when he makes a decision
and obviously if it's the same green bay
story the end but
if it's
requesting a trade
buckle up so you think by next week
could this could happen
uh where he makes his decision because
to me again i don't think he makes a
decision where he really leaves green
bay until he sees something concretely
on the table from green bay because he's
going to have to you know they're going
to have to figure out his cap hits like
46 million if they do want to pay him 50
they got to figure out how to make it
work and then put something on the table
where he realizes okay so it'll be the
2024 draft i'm sitting at home and i'm
surprised by your you drafting somebody
new right i mean like that's yeah that's
the way it's got to work he's got to see
that in a contract before he makes his
decision i would imagine
definitely a part of all this
um and i'm sure he has from what we've
been able to see a lot of this past year
i'm sure there's a lot of personal stuff
too that that's part of this and and
look
there are teams that are in this
that as much as they're doing in terms
of trying to make this work
for what they're for what they're able
to give up for him that still believe at
the end of the day he's going to go back
to green bay
and i think that's really interesting
too and look they have no say they don't
really know what aaron's going to do
themselves right
uh you know organizations that are that
are working hard and perhaps getting
ownership approval on all this
um
you know still think that uh maybe at
the end but we're gonna swing here but
we're gonna probably miss here all right
in the 40 seconds i have left with you
because i do have a old heart out at the
end of the in about a minute plus well i
i'm just getting trying to get to that
warm goodbyes now you know we're kind of
that this is part of the warm goodbye
great stuff diana i'll give you that in
advance um
that uh of the number of teams that you
have spoken to that are in the hunt i
will not ask you to source them
obviously
what number are the whoa i can't believe
that team would actually be in the
rogers hunt you got a number
of that whoa
how many teams would i say like whoa yes
whoa oh i wouldn't say well to any of
them
that they all make sense
got it
diana thanks for the call really
appreciate it i hope to i do hope to see
you in the combine i'll be in the booth
just stop by you know where i'll be
i'll see you good luck have a great week
thanks you too thanks for the call
that's diana russini of espn
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here